This video is brought to you by Skillshare.
Hey, wisecrack, Michael here. If you've worked in an office before,
you've definitely had to deal with that guy. You know,
the one I'm talking about, he sucks up to the boss, treats minor tasks.
Like they are matters of life or death, hides, knives,
and hunting bows throughout the office and skins that face off a dummy.
Okay.
Maybe not those last two,
if it's not obvious yet I'm talking about paper salesman,
beet farmer and Battlestar Galactica, superfan, Dwight K Schrute.
Have you seen the office,
then you probably think of him as the embodiment of the worst possible co-worker
even if he gets a little lovable by the end redemption aside, he's unfriendly,
needlessly,
competitive and obsessed with efficiency in a way that makes him more of an
algorithm than a human at time at 1245,
he sneezed while keeping his eyes open,
which I always thought was impossible.
What if Dwight was actually right now,
we're not claiming the joints antiques weren't horrifying or just plain mean,
but what it is obsession with machine-like efficiency,
without regard for human emotion might end up being better for his peers.
What if paradoxically Dwight is making his working environment better while
simultaneously being the absolute worst? You're welcome.
Welcome to this wisecrack edition on the philosophy of Dwight and spoilers
ahead. But before we get into it, I'm gonna give a shout out to Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community with thousands of inspiring classes
for creative and curious people with skill share,
you can explore new skills and learn more about the ones you already have.
The asset classes on writing design, productivity, illustration,
and so much more.
Their classes are great for teaching you how to channel your creativity into
whatever you are working on right now. I recommend productivity today,
managing attention in the digital age with Kevin's mascot,
the class helped me pay attention to the places I'd been spending.
Most of my time online, I can get lost on social so easily,
and I'd much prefer to spend the time writing or reading.
I learned how to reduce the distractions and prioritize what I actually want to
accomplish during my day.
The best part is that you can complete classes at your own pace and right from
the comfort of your own home,
a premium annual membership is less than $10 a month.
And right now the first 1000 wisecrack fans that click on the link in the
description can get a two month free trial. So check out Skillshare today.
Now back to the show, a quick primer on Dwight,
he starts as a top performing paper salesman and assistant to the regional
manager, Michael Scott.
He also moonlights as a beet farmer and is generally convinced he's better and
smarter than everyone else, too many people on this earth. We need a new plague,
have to show Dwight antagonizes, his coworkers, creating fake fire, panics,
driving them to faraway locations, abandoning them,
and just generally being kind of a Dick. Well,
thanks for wasting my time tonight, but than anything,
the dude is weirdly obsessed with physical strength and efficiency, to.
Give you a reference point. I'm somewhere a snake and Amongus.
He also loves scifi and distrust computers.
We'll get to that to understand why Dwight might actually be a good guy in the
grand scheme of things.
We need to look at a little concept called accelerationism accelerationism has
nothing to do with beet farming or even paper suppliers. Rather.
It's a loosely associated group of thinkers who argue that sometimes the best
way to improve a system is not to improve it at all.
Even going so far as to advocate for speeding up the system,
dysfunction fingers like Karl Marx, Gildea, Luz, and Paul Mason.
Now accelerationist are mostly talking about capitalism.
They think that a capitalism is bad, but B trying to fix it makes it even worse.
The best we can do from their perspective is to let the global financial system
headfirst into its own self destruction,
pushing for better working conditions or a more humane economy for the
accelerationist is the philosophical equivalent of just me.
Now we're not saying Dwight as some accidental Che Guevara,
but if we take the basic premise that if a system is bad,
we should hit the gas and ride it until the wheels fall off.
This is basically what Dwight does unintentionally or not.
One key component of accelerationism is technology technology disrupts.
It makes the world go faster and it also causes a bunch of problems along the
way. What does it mean for technology to accelerate?
Consider the fact it took us thousands of years to go from horse and wagon to
car.
And all of a sudden we said it and we're flying in airplanes and going to the
moon in the same century. More recently,
we might consider the progress from vinyl record to eight track to cassette
tape, to CD to hear it's thousands of songs on your iPod. Just kidding.
It's on your phone now. Instead of course,
it's not all fun games and instant access to the entire discography of the Wu
Tang clan Dunder Mifflin, for example,
starts at ground zero of what technological acceleration is and can mean for
some businesses.
It's a company that provided what was an essential good for virtually every
company in the 1980s and nineties rendered obsolete nearly a decade later by
computers.
Your own employees calculation. You'll be obsolete in the next five to 10 years.
Wait, Ryan said that.
More importantly,
technology in the business world is about efficiency and speed. Now, Dwight,
isn't exactly a fan of computers since they might do a Skynet,
but he's basically trying to turn himself into a machine wearing hydration,
backpacks and peeing into bottles to save time is basically just a Jeff Bezos
fever dream, or just reality for joy work.
Isn't about providing a place for folks to earn a decent living for 40 hours a
week.
It's about sacrificing all individuality and emotion to serve the gods of the
bottom line.
How would I describe myself? Three words,
hardworking alpha male Jack hammer.
Well, it looks like capitalist efficiency for some looks like joblessness and
obsolescence for others as British acceleration is Steve Goodman notes.
We all live in an operating system,
set up by the accelerating triad of war capitalism and emergent AI.
And that operating system doesn't really give a about traditional business or
human values songs. The scary AI, Dwight is all about this.
Even if he spurns consumer technology less did make him weak.
What if we don't want to use a Blackberry because they are stupid and pointless.
Rather he takes on the technological rationale of speed and efficiency,
even at the cost of basic human dignity.
Take the time he was tasked by Michael with picking out a new healthcare plan
for Dunder Mifflin.
Does he take into consideration the diversity of his coworkers health needs to
pick a plan that offers the most comprehensive care number one.
Inverted penis. Could you mean vagina?
Because if you do, I want that.
Hell no. He slashes things down to a bare bones plan to save the company money.
Slashed benefits to the bone. I saved this company money. Was I too harsh?
Maybe I don't believe in coddling people.
Well, his thought process isn't grounded in what's best for human beings.
It's grounded in the tenants of capitalist efficiency,
which he values over humanity. How many.
People can I fire a nun? You're picking a health care plan.
Okay. We'll table that.
The time being now, you might be asking, how is this good?
But consider this what Dwight is doing is probably not much worse than what
anyone from corporate looking to slash costs would have done.
The whole reason that we're doing this is to save money.
So you just need to pick a provider and then choose the cheese.
Instead, Dwight, by embracing the logical extreme of cost,
cutting everyone off to the point that they rebel his actions,
force his coworkers to band together and demand something better.
And maybe without Dwight pushing things,
they would have merely accepted whatever garbage health plan they were offered.
Why did you put Dwight in charge of that? He did a horrible job. Uh, Dwight,
did you raise benefits? I most certainly did not. Okay.
Come on. That's horrible. This is what,
the more progressive advocates for accelerationism hope that by making reality
more extreme, things will actually get better.
And this isn't a completely new theory of change just throughout history.
The most significant revolutions come from extreme circumstances.
Think of the French revolution,
a product of dire poverty among the peasants and ocular wealth amongst the
ruling aristocracy rather than sitting around, waiting for change.
Acceleration is want to pour fuel on the fire.
We can contrast Dwight's brutal logic with his superior. Michael Scott,
who makes terrible fiscal decisions because he's prioritizing the feelings of
the people around him over efficiency.
Wants everything in our company to be about emails and I AM's.
But I think he is forgetting about the original instant message
letters attached to baskets of food.
Whether it's for selfish reasons or not.
Michael airs on the side of people over profits, good manager,
doesn't fire people. He hires people.
If Dwight embodies the futuristic politics of accelerationism,
then Michael embodies an old school,
liberal political philosophy that places emphasis on a decent life for all of
his employees.
Well, you have to tolerate a lot when you're part of a family. It's not family,
it's a workplace.
Rather than Dwight's dystopian vision of efficiency.
Michael seems to prefer something like you would have seen in the rust belt in
the 1950s where working a good job at the factory meant everyone could afford to
start a family and own a home.
But the good thing about the American dream is that you can just go to
sleep and try it all again the next night.
Well,
this all sounds very nice and accelerationist would tell you that it's about as
likely to make a comeback as video rental stores.
Dwight's attitude is more at home in our contemporary era of techno capitalism
than Michael's old school people-based style of business.
As Silicon Valley culture transforms into political ideology principles like
hyper efficiency and automation are becoming touchstones in industries,
ranging from jet propulsion to healthcare, to home cooking.
This innovation involves an open embrace of capitalism in all of its techno
utopian glory Joya from this type of ideology.
When he hunts down time thieves in the company who are wasting even a moment of
their working day on personal inefficiencies, time, thief, fire him.
Right? You've really never stolen. Any company done never.
And while Dwight might fear and detests computers,
it's fitting that his one true worthy adversary is a computer that also sells
paper.
Dwight takes this competitor on winds and in doing so shows that he might be
more machine than man after all,
but we're not arguing that Dwight is secretly a monster only for the sake of
inspiring revolution from his coworkers far from it.
He just wants power and control.
The Japanese camp guards of world war II always chose one man to kill whenever a
batch of new prisoners arrived.
I always wondered how they chose the man who was to die.
I think I would have been good at choosing the person.
We see this tendency at play when Dwight is momentarily.
Given what he thinks is absolute rule over the office or ruthlessness comes to
the surface. The moment he's in power over his own kingdom,
complete with his own evil queen chicken, be in charge of the women.
He seems to be implicitly acknowledging the inefficiencies of traditional
democratic structures. As he installed his own profit prioritizing system,
Dwight rarely gets explicit about his politics,
but we know that he has some definite tendencies towards authoritarianism.
At one point, Jim helps to write out by printing out,
talking points for a speech.
I did download speeches from some of history's famous dictators like this one
originally given by Benito Mussolini.
And because Dwight is Dwight,
he is immediately inspired and empowered by the fascist crows.
Blood alone moves the wheels of history.
And of course there are the frequent ins that Dwight's German ancestors might
have been literal. Now.
My grandpa Manheim is 103 and still puttering around down in
Argentina. I tried to go visit him once,
but my travel visa was protested by the show of Dwight.
Is accelerating for accelerating sake,
not to help break the system and his affinity for fascism yearly resembles the
dangers of accelerationist thinking,
but let's return to the Dwight Michael dichotomy of accelerationism versus old
school liberalism rather than viewing technology and innovation as a mechanism
to unleash the spirit of capitalism to remake the world and its image.
Michael seems to view technology as a threat to the traditions of the American
workplace.
We have learned that you can't teach an old dog new tricks because it's illegal.
Dwight is trying to move beyond the need for human labor. Michael,
can't imagine a world where he's not spending 40 plus hours a week hanging out
under harsh fluorescent lighting with his butts.
Life and business are about human connections
and computers are about trying to murder you in a Lake.
And to me, the choice is easy.
And we see the tension between Dwight and Michael's perspectives.
When they go on a covert mission to gather Intel from a local mom and pop a
paper business,
Michael recoiled in horror at the thought of destroying the business of these
good wholesome people,
Dwight views them as just the acceptable collateral damage of the free market
paradoxically though,
by making the workplace much more pleasant and humane in the short term,
Michael's approach actually keeps things stuck, right where they are.
No one is forming a secret union to overthrow Michael,
just because of the occasional appearance of prison. Mike, on prison, Mike,
speaking of prison, Mike,
he invents the character after his workers realized they'd rather be in a prison
than at work or realization that comes so slowly because their work prison is
obviously skated by Michael's friendly antics.
Dwight who makes things more unbearable in the immediate sense can actually
create the conditions for change by taking systems to their logical,
extreme joy,
even explicitly recognizes his logic when he becomes landlord of the office
building and as antiques go too far,
he takes a Labrot measures to save on building costs,
including half ply toilet paper. Don't get.
Me started on how cuddled the modern anuses.
Afterwards.
He has a legitimate showdown with Pam who threatens to find a new office.
Dwight in typical Dwight fashion thinks of his relationship with his tenants as
a war.
Wanting a building is a war between the landlord and the tenant,
not a literal war, unfortunately, but I am using the same tactics.
Eventually realizes that the best vampires don't drain all the blood from their
victims at once.
They say the best vampires don't bleed their victims dry,
but give them the strength so that they can bounce back only to be fed on again.
In a nutshell, Dwight is realizing that his acceleration,
his practices will lead to open revolt and that he must reign in his short-term
greed for long-term stability.
And whether it be Silicon Valley or Dwight Truett,
the process of acceleration can either make things way better or much worse with
not a lot in between. And a recent example,
Silicon Valley's desire to develop things like facial recognition technology,
because people who see this technology as a wild invasion of privacy to organize
and fight against it complete with a last week tonight, take down.
Okay. And the Terminator Skynet is evil reigns down death from.
This guy, but in China, Skynet is good. Now the difference,
Oh.
That's the difference is it's.
So maybe Dwight's tyranny will ultimately lead to a better workplace,
but maybe it won't by the end of the series,
he establishes himself as the Kim Jong IL of Scranton Pennsylvania paper.
And people seem okay with it.
Maybe Dwight holds onto this power and just makes things even worse for everyone
to Dunder Mifflin,
firing as many folks as he can and creating a living hell for those stuck there.
Get out. What does that mean? It's a colloquial way of saying you're fired.
The danger of acceleration isn't as,
as its critics have noted that maybe the wheels won't come flying off,
maybe things won't get better.
Maybe we'll just end up with Dwight as the boss forever. But what do you think?
Did things have to get worse to get better to we encourage it?
Or is it just too risky? Let us know you think in the comments,
a huge thanks to our amazing patrons for supporting the channel and our podcast
hit that subscribe button and as always, thanks for watching later.